Speaker 1: Okay. We recently told you about a pro
dissent, a super PAC, which released its first
anti-Trump ad. We now have Donald Trump posting a
hard core Ron DeSantis attack ad to truth social
censure. And what's interesting is that some of
the claims that it makes, it's a very aggressive,
very vicious attack ad, but the claims it makes
aren't exactly bulletproof, which might not come
as a shock to you. Let's take a listen.
Speaker 2: To a struggling big time in
his primary race for governor of Florida,
Polls revealed to Sanders was failing so
bad he was losing by a staggering 17 points.
Then dissenters was saved by the endorsement
of President Trump.
Speaker 4: Trump's
support was so powerful. Just two days.
Speaker 2: After the endorsement, DeSantis
took a commanding lead and it propelled him to
being elected. I'd like to thank our president
for standing by me when it wasn't necessarily the
smart thing to do. Here I am. Run. Unfortunately,
instead of being grateful, the Santos is now
attacking the very man who saved his career.
Speaker 4: Hijacked time to Santos, remembers how
he got to where he is. Make America great again.
Speaker 2: Big league. So good.
Build the wall. Then Mr. Trump said,
You're fired. I love that part.
Speaker 4: Truth is, there's only
one person who can make America great again.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So you know this entire thing
about how the day two days after the endorsement,
DeSantis just shot up. I encourage you to go back
and look at the polls. Real Clear Politics has
like a polling, historical polling trend line on
that race. And it is true that eventually DeSantis
surged as the election got close, but it wasn't.
Over the summer, when Trump claims that his
endorsement in 48 hours turned the race around,
it was months later. Now you can debate whether it
was thanks to Trump's endorsement months earlier.
I'm not even trying to have that debate with you.
The story that's being told. DeSantis was dead
and then I endorsed him and 48 hours later,
he was absolutely crushing in the polls. It's
just not what the polling data shows when you
look at it retrospectively. So I do think that,
you know, Trump's in a position where there's
the real reason he's angry with the Santos, and
then there's what stuff can you use to criticize
the Santos? There's a little bit of a dissonance
between the two. The real reason Trump's furious
at DeSantis is that DeSantis not ruling out
running is seen by Trump is totally disloyal. The
problem is Trump's going after DeSantis for like,
for example, saying Trump's sorry. Trump says
Desantis's COVID numbers are terrible. They're
mediocre. They're not terrible. They're not good.
Florida is very mediocre in most metrics. So when
Trump used to praise the Santos on COVID,
now he attacks him on COVID. The truth is,
it was was both sort of like it's not great
in Florida, but they benefit from the warm
weather and people being outdoors. And so, like,
the numbers aren't as bad as they could be. He
wants to cut and cut Social Security. And he voted
for a study group proposal that was nonbinding,
which would have raise the retirement age. Is
that a sort of cut? Yes. Did he really vote
for the cut? Well, everybody knew it wasn't going
anywhere. It was just a study group proposal. Is
that a really strong critique, particularly when
Trump has also said I would look at entitlements?
Not really. And so Trump, if this really gets
going, is going to have to find something a
little more solid, I guess I would say,
with which he can go after Ron DeSantis.